[Music]
like to welcome you to tonight's chess
class on tactics I had prepared some
material from a book I've been used a
new book I've been using as the art of
chess combination by Eugene's NASSCO
borovsky a Russian written back in 1936
but I messed up my file and I didn't
bring the material with me but I do have
a couple that we're going to go through
some examples these are checkmate in two
problems
it's called selected Stassi volume two
it's a bat this is an Italian problem
composer he has won many awards he did
this around 1951 so these are matin -
and these are first prize puzzles that
compositions that he he won in different
or different compositions tournaments
they held around the country so anyway
yeah it's white - matin to make the move
and it's made into the the trick - these
chess problems is to find the first move
for a white that's the key move if you
for it find the right key move every
move that black plays there's a
checkmate for it there might be four to
six different moves for black but
there's a checkmate for every possible
move and I just let you guys analyze it
for a little while it takes a few
minutes one of the things I like to do
with these problems is first I like to
check out the black King make sure that
typically he has no moves legal moves so
I like to see all the squares around the
black King neder and which white pieces
cover them so let's do that
the black King the G three squares
covered by the pawn on f2 and then
f-for the III black squares covered by
the to the pawn on f to the pawn on d2
and the knight on f5 that the Knights on
f5 not at for the F 3 square is covered
only by the night it's very relevant if
you have more than one piece covering a
square for the King so in this case the
knight on G 1 cup is the only white
piece covering f3 so typically you would
not move that night as part of your key
move decision yeah other than that F 5
squares obviously covered by the bishop
and the pawn again you have two pieces
covering the f5 square so the pawn can't
move but the bishop is it could be a
candidate move and then you have the
White Queen hanging around doesn't look
like she has many moves cuz she's
blocked out by the white pawns on e4 d3
at D 2 anyway so you can see the kick
the black King has no moves the next
thing I like to do is look at the White
King and see if there are any moves that
black can check the White King and then
make sure you have a checkmate response
for that so the only piece that can
possibly check the White King is the
Queen and the Queen would go take the
pawn on f2 and the response is right
there where it takes Queen would be
checkmate and the Queen could go to e3
check and the response would be deep the
d2 pawn takes c3 which would be
checkmate so you don't have to worry
about those particular checks anyway
that's all the hints I'm going to give
you feel free to throw out
any suggestions you might have and we'll
see what the computer says
or we'll work through it well you only
use the computer if we have to here's
another approach to this thing look
around we said that the knight could
move because the knight guards the III
and the G three squares right but so
does the pawn so there's two upon in a
piece now look if you move that night
where it would be a checkmate well I see
a checkmate on g2 if the knight could
get to g2 that would be a checkmate
wouldn't it so the question is from what
squares can the knight get to g2 so I
would suggest you consider those
possibilities all right let's look at
that so we bring the knight back and the
threat is the knight on G three takes to
the Queen checkmate now what's your
answer to Queen takes pawn check you
have one move to checkmate me it's not
gonna be easy because your nights
hanging no you're in check I'm not
checking into your king yeah and if you
take my queen I take your knight and
you'd lost that was your second move so
Knight to g3 is interesting but it
doesn't quite cut cut it okay so let's
go back all right
we're back at the starting position
let's look at that that's a good try
so now the threat is night to g2 check
mate and we can't do Queen takes Knight
because as we said the D to pawn would
take that would be checkmate
however the knight move from f5 you
freed up the g3 square so if I take the
pawn with the Queen again all I have to
do that Newberry Queen takes pawn now if
you do rook takes Queen I get to go to
g3 again no f3 is open and if you go
Knight 2 G 2 cuz the Queen's pinned
I got King to g3 and if the Queen goes
stuff 7 check I can interpose the Bishop
Bishop to f6
so let's chalk Knight to the III up is a
good try
but that's not the only square that you
could get to g2 from and oh by the way
g2 isn't the only possible checkmate
threat
I might have led you guys astray by
focusing your attention on g2 you might
want to consider other possible checks
by the knight on other squares so one of
the defenses we've seen in the Tri so
far is Queen takes pawn check right is
there a move we can make that would
prevent Queen takes pawn check would
block the check let's look at that what
should blacks defensive move be now Alex
okay
the escape square is g5 is that correct
all right night East six is checkmate
all right now let's see if there's any
other defenses so the threat is Knight
to e6 checkmate what happens if I pin
the night with Queen takes pawn what do
you do oh the other night the other
night
there's our checkmate all right we're
getting there yes is there any other
defense Queen we're right right that's
that's if one of the main lines right I
think you got it let me check the
official answer book 321 so Knight to d4
get some exclamation mark
congratulations
and it says Oh Queen takes e4 I don't
think we tried that
yep that does it they yeah Queen takes
Queen okay alright so that's that one
how about Queen takes f2 we did that one
okay Queen takes f 2g 3G three ah yes
Knight to h3 we open up yet another
check don't we
okay let's see we did eat to d4 and if
the bishop if the black bishop moves we
already said the night goes to e6 and
delivers checkmate let's look at the
second example I just keyed in this one
has more pieces this might be harder for
you it's also a number one a first prize
in the Netherlands problem society a
theme composition event that they had
yep white to play meeting to mate in to
that you have to find the key move the
first move for white whatever black does
there's a checkmate so it's made in two
moves white to play mate in two
I see Dennis has joined us you missed
the first problem so we're going to work
you out on this one we stared at him for
20 minutes to a half hour sometimes this
one is awfully crowded there's a lot of
possible moves to consider oh okay
does anyone have a suggestion well let's
play through it it may help us what's
the move you're looking at that's a
check and remember Alex said typically
you don't start with a check so there
must be an answer well if it's worth to
see through you that Bishop takes c3
check and there no it's escape our
pieces to block in that check so work to
c3 doesn't cut it does it oh b2 and then
work to c3 right right that would be
three moves all right well that that was
interesting you were trying to make use
of the advancing upon with the
discovered check that's always a good
tactical idea it just didn't quite make
it this time
yeah I'll just carry it out a little
further
that's the defense check and that was
the ight but it unfortunately it is
checkmate but it's right right so so we
have to find something else
okay what do you think Knight to g7
what's your threat that's an excellent
idea that's a great mating idea in this
position now let's see if there are any
defenses we have to guard the d6 square
right Black has to guard the d6 square
let's block let's oh oh yeah yeah okay
let's blow up guard with this Knight
move now is there checkmate yeah I guess
this seems to solve the problem so let's
go back any other ideas I had an idea I
was looking at it earlier I noticed that
I could play Knight to e8 and threaten
Knight takes Knight which would be a
checkmate and I still and I threaten
your idea of work to deselect mate let's
look at that anyone see a solution to
that
okay night f2g five but that leaves the
bishop unprotected we have to find a
better defense for black
how about is there a checkmate if we do
Knight takes Knight oh yeah Queen takes
bishop jet is checkmate there too so
Knight takes Knight we also have Queen
takes Queen takes bishop that's the
checkmate so that doesn't work I do
believe there is one now let me see if I
can remember what it was
okay
okay okay rook to e4 how does that
defend rook
oh you have the f5 square oh very good
very good Alex
all right we work the e4 I don't anyone
see a checkmate here
they can go here they're feeding our two
moves alright I think Alex found it so
that's the problem with Knight to d8
back to the drawing board okay I haven't
thought of that let's see what that is
your threat is obviously Knight takes
Knight checkmate that pawned that didn't
wasn't doing anything important was it
yeah oh it was blocking the work to see
seven check okay so yeah that kills it
okay all right good enough
you can well let's know the night can
block right
the night
Oh what was the loose d8 queen
what was the recommended move oh the
check that's right
and if the Queen takes the night blocks
and we put off meat for one moves oh
yeah okay we're running out of
possibilities so I think we're never
running it down no mate entry doesn't
cut it they wouldn't get the first prize
in matin to cop competition if it took
three moves I'm going to give you guys a
big hint all you have to remember is the
same the it's the same move in our last
problem what was that Alex let's look at
night 2d for threatening work 2d six
checkmate how can black defend that
night after okay hold on overnight after
g5 Wow we still have Queen takes bishop
checkmate okay how about another try
how about the other night yep Queen f4
that cuts it doesn't it okay
how about another try so we can't do the
Knights
we if we can try Bishop to f6 Jack it's
useless of course but it is a move and
of course Queen takes bishop checkmate
rook what okay let's look at it which
Knight move is checkmate the be Knight
the denied okay oh you're right right
yep there's your checkmate okay I think
that's the solution let's me double
check what the what it says in the book
no yeah rook C takes c3 I don't think we
looked at that night D oh we did look at
the night D to see six of those didn't
weigh in some other line the brook spins
so it can't four take the knight now if
the other work takes Knight to f3 is the
checkmate because the rook is pinned by
the bishop
that's the purpose of that bishop behind
the pawn it wasn't the discovered check
it was this line to pin the rook okay
let's see we also have that back here
Knight to g4 we have the knight f2 moves
anywhere the answers Queen takes h8
takes the bishop checkmate Knight H to
g5 we looked at that ATS Queen takes f4
bishop yeah that's it that's everything
okay let's do this one I'll set it up
well I think this is it
let me it is their legal position I got
something wrong okay
what's illegal a good point thanks but
you usually helps the problems it's hard
it's checkmate Avena king alright
alright
it misses it I'm afraid this is another
first place
now I haven't looked at this so I can't
be hint any help either so but we have
ten minutes let's see if we can solve it
in ten minutes now the check and not a
capture so you don't need to waste your
time on those moves usually occasionally
I have seen captures occasionally but
it's quite rare I tell you one thing
that puzzles me right off the bat is
what on earth does that White Queen have
to do with this composition okay okay
okay okay wait we have an answer to your
Queen 10h a six check we swing the rook
from efore and block the check with rook
to be for getting a discovered check but
we have to we have to guard the e5
square so the King can't escape to e5 so
we move the knight somewhere protecting
the e5 square it's got to be the knight
on d6 I think cuz that opens up the rook
to d6 checkmate idea huh wait a minute
let's try this move
cleany oh yeah there's no I its wait a
minute there I can block the check and
get a discovered check huh oh
kingi five okay you killed that idea
where can I go and protect the e5 square
let's try a night here wait a minute
let's try a night here oh now I don't
have the he has Queen there check and I
don't have a discovered check do i Queen
the a3 check and I don't have an answer
ya don't have an answer okay let's look
at the answer I give up Knight takes off
seven is the right move now the retort
what was the retort Alex go you said
Knight to f6 right
oh we still have work to do now we had
our thread that was that was the answer
and other than that let's see let me go
back so work takes night we have Queen
takes rook checkmate thicket that's what
the Queen's doing there okay well good
enough let's wrap it up for the next
lesson those will definitely give you a
headache won't they
[Music]
you